The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
MATT WILSON: Now, why are
we interested in sleep?
So, we kind of think about
this as two modes, online mode
and offline mode.
In the online mode, you're
taking information in.
In the offline mode,
you're going back
and evaluating information.
What's the purpose of
evaluating information
that you've taken in?
Well, if we think about
the general problem that's
being solved, the
problem of intelligence.
The problem of intelligence is
trying to understand and infer
these sort of deep generalizable
relationships rules.
You're trying to extract
rules from instances.
And you'd like those
rules to be as generally
applicable as possible.
And in order to do
that, presumably, one
has to go back and evaluate
the many individual instances
to try to extract some kind
of statistical regularity,
and then perhaps evaluate
models that you have constructed
in terms of their consistency
with individual instances
that you've already collected.
Or perhaps future instances
that you haven't yet.
So you have the raw material,
you build a little model,
and then you continually
test that model
against new information
that comes in.
And the question is,
when can you do that?
Now, you could do
that when you're
out and about in the world.
As you saw and read in that
paper, when animals are sitting
quietly, they very
quickly can switch
into this kind of offline mode
that looks a lot like sleep.
In fact, electrophysiologically,
sleep and quiet wakefulness
in the hippocampus are
nearly indistinguishable.
It's the same kind
of offline mode.
It says, OK, when the
hippocampus is not
being used to take
new information in,
I quickly switch into this
offline evaluation mode.
But during sleep, I no
longer have the constraint
of having to direct behavior.
Behavior's shut off,
inputs are shut off,
and now I can switch into this
purely internal introspective
mode.
So what goes on during sleep.
In this simple experiment,
we look at the activity
when the animal is
performing behavioral tasks.
And then we examine
activity during sleep,
both before and after,
and ask, is there
anything about
behavioral experience
that changes activity
during sleep?
And what we found was that
if you look at activity
during behavior
in which you think
about these spatial
sequences being expressed,
and you look during
sleep afterward,
you find that the spatial
sequences are expressed again.
So the hippocampus replays the
firing of these cell sequences.
But it replays the firing
of these cell sequences
at a time scale that appears
to be compressed relative
to the behavioral timescale.
So these are eight place cells.
Animals were walking
from left to right.
The ticks indicate that's
the location of the peak.
So these place cells will
fire one through eight
as the animal moves along the
track over about five seconds.
That's how long it
takes the animal
to walk from left to right.
The same sequence of
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8
gets replayed during
sleep, but now
over about 150 milliseconds.
Same sequence, so you're
preserving time order,
not absolute time.
And that when you ask, when
these sequences are expressed,
what's going on in the
local field potential
in these oscillations?
And this is where you find
these sharp wave ripple events.
This is this ripple-like event
that I was describing to you.
So these sharp wave
ripples are when
these apparently compressed
sequences are being expressed.
I could point out that a simple
model for these sharp wave
ripple reactivated sequences
is the same model that I like
to use to explain
phase precession
during the fade oscillation.
That is, I give it an
input, I sweep inhibition
from high to low such that cells
that are getting the strongest
input fire earlier.
And this will
reactivate a sequence.
So the difference
between a theta sequence
and a reactivated
sequence is really just,
where's the input coming from.
If the input's coming from what
I'm actually experiencing right
now, now it's a theta sequence.
And as I move, the input
changes systematically.
And so, again, it looks like
it's encoding information
about space.
If I'm now offline,
and this information
is being delivered
to the hippocampus
from some other
source, you can apply
exactly the same operation,
get the same kind of sequence.
It's just now it's
on information
that is not tied to your
immediate context or location.
That's the only difference.
Where is the input coming from?
Now further, if you
think about this model,
you can imagine the
depth of disinhibition
could actually affect the
length of the sequence.
But that's just sort
of a mechanistic thing.
And if you actually look
at the mechanisms that
regulate sharp wave ripples
in the theta oscillation,
it basically comes from
the same structure.
It's a structure that
regulates acetylcholine,
and it's a neuromodulator
that's associated
with attention and
memory, and the structure
called the medial septum.
So the medial septum
provides the drive,
the cholinergic drive,
of the hippocampus.
Damage to the medial septum,
loss of cholinergic tone,
was one of the dominant models
of neurodegenerative cognitive
and memory loss in
Alzheimer's disease.
So what you find is
one of the earliest
indications of neurodegenerative
damage in Alzheimer's is
the loss of cholinergic tone.
And the systems that
begin to break down
are the systems that
actually fall along
this limbic pathway starting
with hippocampus-entorhinal
cortex.
So it's as though the
cholinergic system that
regulates the expression of this
oscillation in the hippocampus,
when it breaks down, it
leads to general memory
loss and disruption.
And it turns out the
medial septum is also
involved in regulating the
expression of these sharp wave
ripples.
So, same system,
different modes.
One quite active, online.
One inactive, offline.
Same kind of modulation
of excitability
through inhibition.
But that's the idea.
Simple model, sweep inhibition,
that gives you the sequences.
And then if you can
control the input,
you control the input
to control the content,
you control the
inhibition to control
the structure of the timing.
Those are the two things.
So the question is, how
could you control the input?
Well, you're kind of
thinking about what
is the input into
the hippocampus
under these two conditions.
And as I mentioned,
hippocampus, you've
got the entorhinal cortex.
Entorhinal cortex gets
information across the brain.
It's sort of these
sensory association areas,
visual cortex, auditory cortex.
So all this information
about the world
converging on the hippocampus
and then getting modulated.
And so let's look in, for
instance, the visual cortex.
So if we simultaneous
record visual cortex
and the hippocampus, we could
see how these two structures
communicate.
And when we do this
in a simple task--
this is like a little
figure eight task--
and I won't go into
a lot of the details.
But one interesting
thing that came out
from doing this
experiment, recording
the visual cortex
and the hippocampus,
is that recording in the visual
cortex when an animal is moving
in space, what you find is
cells in the visual cortex
have spatial-like
receptive fields.
Similar to the hippocampus,
though not as spatially tuned.
But here, for instance, are
eight visual cortical cells.
And you can see that
they fire in a sequence.
They'll have different
spatial receptive fields.
This shows where this one visual
cortical cell likes to fire.
Different visual
cortical cells will
fire at different locations.
So when animals are
moving in space,
you actually see
sequential activation
of these visual
cortical responses.
And so if you have visual
perceptual sequences
in hippocampal
spatial sequences,
one question is, how
do those sequences
relate offline when the animal,
for instance, during sleep.
So you have sequences
during sleep
in the hippocampus,
sequences during sleep
in the visual cortex.
And it turns out that those two
things are actually correlated.
So when hippocampus plays
out a spatial sequence,
the visual cortex plays
out a visual sequence
that corresponds to the visual
responses at those locations.
So hippocampus
plays out a sequence
of where it was,
visual cortex expresses
the visual stimuli that were
present along that sequence.
One thing about
these sequences when
we're looking at hippocampal
neocortical interactions
is that the sequences are now
at a much longer time scale.
And in fact this
time scale, which
here is on the order of about
half a second to a second,
corresponds to
another oscillation
that is characteristic of sleep
known as the slow oscillation.
So when you go to
sleep, brain rhythm,
the oscillations, the dominant
frequencies start to slow down.
And you'll get this
oscillation in this one
hertz or so frequency range.
If you record activity
from a bunch of cells,
it looks like this.
This is the activity
of a whole bunch
of cells in the visual
cortex in the hippocampus.
And you see that the activity is
flipping between lots of cells
active, no cells active.
These are the
so-called up and down
states of cells during sleep.
That every half a second to
a second or so many cells
will become active, then
they'll all be shut off,
then they'll become
active again.
So you are flipping between
these up and down-like states.
And if you look at
these up and down states
in the visual
cortex, and you look
at similar activity
in the hippocampus,
you see these up and down-like
states in the hippocampus
as well.
But you'll notice that the
up state in the neocortex
leads up state in
the hippocampus.
So neocortex first, then
hippocampus, neocortex,
hippocampus.
Neocortex seems to lead.
So again, this question of,
who's providing the input?
That simple model where
I'm sweeping inhibition
during the theta, during active
behavior, that information
is coming in from perception,
is what I'm saying.
During sleep, the question
is, where is that information
coming from?
Well, this would say, this
is where it's coming from.
It's coming from
these cortical areas.
Let's say sensory, visual
cortical areas turn on.
They provide the information
to the hippocampus.
Now the hippocampus turns
on, and the hippocampus
responding to input coming
in from the sensory cortex.
Now, if that's
the case, could we
manipulate hippocampal
activity by manipulating
the sensory cortex?
And so this experiment, simple
experiment, answer was yes.
In this case we use
the auditory system.
One of the reasons to
use the auditory system
is that, unlike
the visual system,
the auditory system remains in
a state of persistent vigilance,
even during sleep.
Auditory cortical
responses, even when
the animal goes
to sleep, measure
auditory cortical responses
same as when it's awake.
So essentially the
auditory cortex
stays vigilant
during sleep, which
has clear evolutionary value.
Animal's asleep, it's
trying to minimize arousal
by shutting off visual input,
which may be of limited value
anyway, given the
circadian nocturnal nature
of visual stimuli.
So if you can't see
anything, you might as well
actually close your eyes.
But you can still hear things.
So you and other
animals are still
listening to pick up
threats that might require
that they actually wake up.
So anyway, taking
advantage of that.
Auditory system on, so
train an animal on task
where it learns to associate
auditory cues with locations.
Right sound means go
over here to get food,
left sound means go
over there to get food.
Very simple task.
Then animal goes to
sleep, and you just
continue to play the sounds.
So it's learned something.
And now you try to bias cortical
activity during sleep and ask,
what does that do?
And so this is the idea.
When the animal is
actually running,
we can decode
hippocampal activity.
So we can tell, oh, here's
the hippocampal pattern that
corresponds to the left
side or the right side.
And in this case, when the
animal's performing the task,
play the right-hand
sound, animal
goes to the right-hand
side, see this
in the hippocampal response.
Play the left-hand sound, animal
goes to the left-hand side.
Again, the left-hand
place fields
when the animal's on the
left, right-hand place
fields on the right.
So this is what the
experiment and the behavior
looks like from the
standpoint of the hippocampus.
Very clear, right?
Right sound, right
hippocampus, right place cells.
Left sound, left place cells.
But now the animal's
going to go to sleep,
and we're going to
do the same thing.
Continue to play the right
sounds and the left sounds.
It's just that now the
animal is not actually
moving on the track.
And so we ask,
does that-- can we
bias the reactivated
sequences that you get?
So there's the same thing now.
Animal's awake, but now
it's going to go to sleep,
and we just keep
playing the sounds.
The little tics there indicate
the delivery of sounds
every 10 seconds or so.
So we play a sound, and now
we look at the response.
The difference here is that
the animal's not running,
it's not behaving.
Sound, response.
Now we'll decode the activity.
So here, for instance, we take
a little short window here,
about half a second.
And what you see is this
is this up-like state.
Multi-unit activity,
lots of cells firing.
Decode activity.
Now ask when you
play the left sound,
what does activity decode to?
And here you see it's going to
decode into the left-hand side.
So that's the basic hypothesis.
Play the left sound,
you get the replay
of the left side of the track.
You play the right sound,
you get reactivation
of the right side of the track.
And that's what you get.
So when you play
the left-hand sound,
left sound bias activates
place cells on the left side.
Right side bias biases
place cells on the right.
And you can do the same kind
of psychophysical experiments
which has been done in humans,
either with different sensor
modalities-- it's been
done in olfaction.
It's also been done in audition.
So the equivalent
experiment, using auditory
cueing in humans, where you have
people learn the simple task.
And this was done
in Ken Paller's lab
where they do the simple
spatial matching game.
It's like, you know,
where's the cat card,
where's the teapot card?
The variant here is when they
flipped over the cat card,
they would play the
cat sound, a meow.
When they flip over
the teapot sound,
they play a little associated
auditory cue, teapot whistle.
And then people go to sleep.
And during sleep, they would
play either the cat sound
or the teapot sound.
And they found that
when they would wake up
and now they do the task,
if they played the cat
sound during sleep,
they were better
at remembering the location
of the cats than the whistle.
So this says not only does sleep
actually contribute to memory,
but it's selective.
And not only is it selective,
but it can be influenced.
It can be biased.
You can direct the
nature memory processing.
And then our experiments
suggest that, well,
one of the consequences of
this kind of sleep manipulation
would be to bias the
memory reactivation
in the hippocampus.
And so the idea is simple.
That is that cortex
biases the state
that the hippocampus gets.
And then the hippocampus takes
that state, sweeps inhibition,
replays a sequence,
and that sequence then
gets played back to the cortex.
So the cortex, it
sort of knows--
it has these sort
of discrete states
that doesn't necessarily know
what the causal correlations
might be.
What happens next?
It doesn't necessarily
know what happens next.
It knows what happened.
Hippocampus knows
what happened next.
It has lots of instances
of that though.
Well, I saw a red light,
what happens next?
You say, oh, you
know, I saw red light,
and all the cars stopped.
OK, that's great.
If I'm just the cortex,
that's what I learned.
All the car stop.
If I'm the hippocampus, I'm a
little bit smarter than that.
I say, you know, last Tuesday I
was there, there's a red light,
and all the cars, except
for these cyclists.
Man, they didn't stop,
they just kept on going.
So wait a minute,
there's a rule.
Red light, cars stop,
bicycles don't stop.
So you have to refine what
appear to be simple rules.
Often that's actually
used in an example.
How do you use the
prefrontal cortex?
Oh, red light means stop,
green light means go.
That's great, except in the real
world, that rule is too simple.
It has to be refined based upon
your particular experience.
In fact, if you're
really sophisticated,
red light means cars, except
for cabbies, will stop, right?
If I see a cabbie, guaranteed
that guy's not going to stop,
he's going to accelerate, right?
And that's the kind of
information-- that's
what the hippocampus has.
And so you imagine
that's what's going on.
Neocortex, in each one of
these slow oscillations,
is saying red light.
And the hippocampus says,
oh, yeah, OK, cars stop.
Red light again.
Well, there was that bicycle
thing, bicycles continue to go.
Red light.
Well, that was the
cabbie incident.
So now you have all these
sort of causal sequences
that are being expressed
back to the neocortex,
presumably in order to establish
this more comprehensive,
consolidated model of
real world traffic lights,
rather than the
cartoon traffic lights.
And so that would be the idea
of what's going on during sleep.
Now, during quiet
wakefulness you
can think of the
same sort of idea.
And that is that you're
kind of evaluating
multiple casual contingencies.
Each of which might be
expressible as a simple rule,
but might also be experienced
as distinct variations
of that rule.
And the idea is, OK,
do we use the rule,
or do we use the exceptions,
or how do we actually
refine the rule based upon
these different instances
or exceptions?
And so you can think about
that as refining the rule,
that's like the learning side.
Applying the rule, that's the
memory or decision making side.
So you can think about,
during quiet wakefulness,
this reactivation being used in
the service of actual learning
or in decision making.
And so again, you
read the paper,
and one of the things that we
had discovered interestingly
about reactivation
during quiet wakefulness
was that when animals stop
after running on a track,
they do reactivate sequences.
This is raw data, animal
running from left to right
and then stopping for
a long period of time.
And you can see activity.
There are these
bursts of activity.
You blow these things up, these
are these sharp wave ripples.
They last about
half a second or so.
So you see a burst
of activity, you
see these place cell sequences.
In this case the
sequence actually
runs in time reversed fashion.
So in this case--
time reversed fashion-- this
doesn't seem like planning
or decision making.
It may be evaluation of
temporal correlations
that might be relevant
to behavior and learning.
But what would a
reverse sequence
actually have to do with
spatial learning and memory?
The insight into how
this might be used
came from computational models.
In fact, computational models
that the post-doc in this case,
Dave Foster, who
made this discovery,
had used in his doctoral work.
Where he was actually
building models,
reinforcement learning
models of spatial navigation.
And one of the problems
in reinforcement learning
is that reinforcement
often comes
after you've actually
carried out the steps that
lead up to it.
In other words, you
walk from left to right,
you get rewarded
when you get here.
What you want to
know is not just,
this is where the reward is.
What you really want
to know is, what
were the things that
actually lead up to that?
In other words, I want to
take credit, reward value,
and I want to spread
it backward in time
to place value on the
things that predict
or lead up to reward.
The so-called temporal
credit assignment problem.
How do I give credit to things
that actually lead up to
or predict reward?
And thinking about how you
might solve the temporal credit
assignment problem, this
reverse reactivation
actually has the capacity to
solve that problem in one step.
If you imagine when the
animal gets to the end,
gets some reward,
and if now at that
point I pair the delivery
of reward signal,
which I will indicate here as--
this is a cartoon
suggesting this is dopamine,
a reward signal.
And I'm going to pair that
with the reverse sequence.
And now you can think
of the association.
This is my current location.
This is way back
where I started from.
Current location gets
paired with strong reward.
Remote location gets
paired with low reward.
So this association
will essentially solve,
will convolve this discrete
reward impulse function,
will turn it into
this continuous graded
monotonic reward
gradient function.
Translating this into this
essentially in one step.
So the thinking is, hey,
animals are actually
using this to learn,
and they're using
this to solve the
temporal credit assignment
problem in a way that
would be important for
general reinforcement learning.
Now, I won't go into--
so, we actually
did this experiment
recorded from the reward area,
the VTA, and the hippocampus.
And, indeed, during these
reactivation events,
you see the pairing of
this reward signaling.
And not only do
you see the pairing
of the reward
signaling, but you find
pairing of the reward
signaling in which
the precise firing
of reward signals
map onto the delivery of
rewards at goal locations.
So it's not just certain
sequences are good,
others are bad.
It's that there are
certain locations
along the sequence that have
differential reward value.
So there's a mapping of
relative reward to location.
And that if you look at this
while animals are actually
performing a task you can see
biases in these sequences that
correspond to planning.
So both of these
elements of sequence
reactivation-- this was some
work by Dave Foster where
he looked at an animal that
has to just forage and find
a location space.
When animals are
searching for a location,
and you look at these
reactivated sequences,
it turns out that
reactivated sequences
tend to be directed
toward the locations
where the animal thinks
the goal might be.
So it's sort of
thinking about things
that would lead to reward.
So both sides of this kind
of sequential computation
seem to be expressed
in the hippocampus.
Co-expression with reward
during evaluation or learning.
The expression during
reward directed behavior
in the service of planning
and decision making.
And then finally, this is
the paper that you had read.
It's just looking at the
structure of these reward
sequences on long tracks.
And the most salient point
that came out of this paper
is that the phenomena of
sharp wave ripple sequential
activation that correspond
to these theta sequences,
when animals are sitting quietly
over the course of these longer
up state like events, takes the
form of bursts of sharp wave
ripples, or sequences of
these short sequences.
So there's this
compositional notion
that you form long sequences
out of little short sequences.
And the other question
is, how do you actually
put these short
sequences together,
and why would you have
a representation that
has this kind of
compositional structure?
It's the Lego
block kind of idea,
where I can put together
sequences from these more
elemental sequential units.
I won't show the movie,
but if I actually
zoom in on one of
those sequences
in that particular instance
where the animals stop,
you can see there's
a longer reactivated
sequence that actually takes the
form of four shorter sequences.
That's how long sequences
are being evaluated.
And one interesting
thing about this
was that if you look at
these different sequences
of different length, shorter
sequences, longer sequences,
they all seem to have
a fixed velocity.
And that is, there's this kind
of a fixed-- what I've heard
is the speed of thought.
So there is some
fixed constraint
that evaluating further
out in the future
simply takes more time.
And so that suggests
that there's
an interesting
constraint in capacity
for extended
evaluation that comes
in the form of these oscillatory
modes of the slow oscillation.
Longer, or slower, frequencies
give you, essentially,
more time, longer sequences.
And that, potentially, if
you want to go even longer,
you might actually
even link sequences
across subsequent cycles.
Just as you could do across
successive sharp wave ripples,
you might be able to do that
across successive slow waves.
So the idea that you have these
oscillations that you can link
or couple sequences
across different cycles
of these oscillations,
that you have oscillations
at different
frequencies, suggests
that this is the mechanism.
It's the compositional
mechanism for sequences that
are nested within oscillations.
By combining these
oscillations you
can construct these sequences in
ways that presumably contribute
to cognition.
So we now kind of see how
things are structured,
and now the question is, can
we actually manipulate it?
And so that's really
the challenge.
Seeing the
compositional structure,
having demonstrated potential
access, the ability to bias
content.
To coord, to bias the
structure of when things occur,
what actually occurs.
Now I think the capacity
exists to essentially engineer
the sequences themselves.
And that is that, during the
sleep or quiet wakeful states,
get animals to think about
things that they have not
actually experienced, and
test the hypothesis that this
is what animals are using
to construct these models,
to essentially tinker with the
blocks of memory and cognition.
And then finally, just
pointing out, it's interesting.
These ripple sequences,
same space and time scale
as theta sequences.
So again, it's suggesting
this is the fundamental unit.
It's not unique to
the hippocampus.
Essentially any
brain system could
express this kind of structure
using that simple model.
Where you see ramps and
you see oscillations,
you're going to get sequences.
And this capacity is something
that probably is broadly
expressed and enjoyed by
different brain areas.
So, there you go.